The heroes of Wayne on YouTube Premium go
on one wild journey over the course of the
show's rollicking first season.
Where do their adventures leave them, and
what might happen to them next?
This is the ending of Wayne explained.
Before you start watching the series, the
name Wayne makes the show sound like it could
be about basically anything.
But by the time the first season is over,
it feels like a title that tells you all you
need to know.
What's the show about?
Well, it's about that kid Wayne, that absolute
madman, the Robin Hood-meets-Dirty Harry of
Brockton, Massachusetts.
How else could you describe it?
"Who's that?"
"That's f---in' Wayne."
Neither hero nor anti-hero, the protagonist
of Wayne is more like a force of nature, a
teenage dispenser of violent justice whose
reputation precedes him.
Everywhere he goes, his legend grows, with
his enemies being left bruised, bloodied,
or — in the case of Del's daddy — with
their nose half-bitten off.
But no matter how mythical Wayne is, he's
far from the show's only focus.
The second half of the equation is his classmate
Del.
Which is definitely not short for nothing,
so don't ask.
"Delilah!
Delilah!"
The two teens are bonded by a traumatic home
life, social outcast status, and a tendency
to talk with the heaviest Boston accents in
the history of the east coast.
"I don't think it's got good-for-you stuff
in it, like vitamins and all that.
Like orange juice and pretzels."
"Pretzels don't got vitamins."
"I'm pretty sure they do."
"Right.
Pretzel vitamins."
Wayne and Del spend the majority of the season
making their way down the east coast to Ocala,
Florida, supposedly for the purpose of retrieving
a gold Trans Am that used to belong to Wayne's
late father.
The car is the closest thing Wayne has to
a birthright, being put together with real
passion by his dad before it was lost to Wayne's
absentee mother, Maureen.
Since then, it's ended up in the possession
of Curtis and Reggie, the hellishly criminal
father and son duo she ends up living with
down south.
At the start of the series, getting the car
back makes for such a thin motivation to cross
the country that it almost feels like a part
of the show's big joke.
But when Wayne and Del actually arrive in
Ocala near the season's end, it quickly becomes
clear to Del that Wayne came all this way
for reasons more emotional than he at first
revealed.
He doesn't just want a family heirloom — he
wants family.
If he can get the Trans Am back from Reggie,
his dirtbag stepbrother — if you can even
really call him that — then all the better.
As capable as he is on his own, Wayne is still
just a teenager looking for somewhere to belong.
He's so desperate for it that he'd drive across
the country to seek affection and acceptance
from the mother who abandoned him when he
was only five.
So what if she lives in, as Del calls it,
"a white trash fortress of meth-heads and
crocodiles"?
After Wayne's dad dies, she and her horrid
new family are all he has left.
"Oh my God.
I'm sorry, do you not care about how your
son's been doing for the past 11 g------ years?"
"Has it been 11 g------ years?"
Wayne never talks about any of this, of course.
Though he's not what you'd call nervous around
people, Wayne is a definite introvert, keeping
his emotions and thoughts guarded at pretty
much all times.
Arriving with Del in Florida is the first
time that he really shows any vulnerability,
and his mother's such a terrible person that
the effort doesn't really pay off.
At the start of the show, many of Wayne's
Brockton-based antagonists, like police Sergeant
Geller and Del's dad and brothers see only
malicious evil in Wayne's behavior.
They make assumptions of his character, based
on the trail of broken bones and blood he
tends to leave behind him.
As they follow his tracks toward Florida,
Wayne's pursuers think that he's a madman
in a bad way.
At first, they figure he kidnapped Del — a
somewhat reasonable assumption, considering
the barbaric level of damage he inflicted
on Del's family.
But when they start asking questions to the
people who've met Wayne, and stayed on his
good side, they uncover a different take on
the fugitive teen.
Wayne is feared by his enemies, sure — but
he's motivated solely by a desire to do good.
"No matter how bad life
treated you or betrayed you, from where I'm
sitting, everything you do, it's done out
of love."
The source of Wayne's chaotic good nature
comes out in Ocala, when Wayne is catching
up with his mother and her new family for
the first time in more than a decade.
We learn from Mo's recollections that Wayne
is following in the footsteps of his father,
who was something of a hometown legend himself
as a younger man.
Wayne's father, Mo explains, always had a
certain code of honor, along with a notorious
intensity known to drive neighbors out of
town.
Everything was always black and white with
him, she says — right or wrong, with no
middle ground.
Sure sounds familiar, doesn't it?
Just like that, we finally learn almost everything
we need to know about why Wayne is the way
he is.
It's a little bit of nature, and a little
bit of nurture — or the lack thereof.
At the end of the show's first season, Wayne
and Del's trail of destruction finally catches
up with them.
Sergeant Geller manages to arrest Wayne, with
arrangements being made to send him back to
Brockton to face the justice system.
Del tries to escape with Wayne, but her father
and brothers catch up with them too, stopping
them in their tracks and successfully shepherding
her away from him, whether she likes it or
not.
The season seems to end with both protagonists
at a personal low, having been captured by
everything they were trying to run away from.
Del is back with her terrible family, and
Wayne is incarcerated, probably not for the
last time in his life.
But while their physical circumstances at
the season's end may be less than ideal, both
characters have grown emotionally, becoming
better people than they've ever been before.
On a personal level, Wayne ends the last episode
in an almost triumphant place.
After the death of his father, he migrated
south to see if he could find a new home with
family there.
Instead, they all took turns trying to kill
each other while his mother sipped wine.
Now Wayne knows what the real score is.
His future's not with family.
His salvation is with Del.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.